and another thought that really helped
me when I was getting critiqued and
asked myself well is this really the job
for me can I really do it in these
situations I asked myself okay what is
really the worst thing that can happen
to you if you do lose the job if you get
kicked out if you get fired what will
you do next I often taught myself well
what is the worst that can happen to me
even if I don't need to accept a job
which maybe pays me a quarter less than
my current job I would still be able to
live a very comfortable life and
probably even get a significantly better
work-life balance so what is really the
problem here anyways so all in all
whenever I got tough negative feedback
like that the mindset that I tried to
adopt over time is that you know well I
will try to do my very best every single
day and if in the end this turns out to
be not enough then this is what it is
okay then I need to look for something